I have been long so fascinated and
amazed by so many aspects of Netflix
you're full of surprises if I may say so
one of those surprises happened I think
about six six years ago so the company
back then was doing really well but you
were basically a streaming service for
other people's films and TV content you
persuaded Wall Street that you were
right to make the kind of radical shift
away from just sending people DVDs so
you're doing it by streaming and you
were growing like a weed you had more
than six million subscribers and healthy
growth rates and yet you chose that
moment to kind of make a giant really a
bet the company decision what was that
decision and what motivated it well
cable networks from all time have
started on other people's content and
then grown into doing their own
originals so we knew with the general
idea for quite a while and we had
actually tried to get into original
content back in 2005 when we were on DVD
only and buying films at Sundance Maggie
Gyllenhaal sherry baby we published on
deep we were a mini studio and it didn't
work out because we were subscale and
then as you said in 2011
Ted Saran those my partner and Netflix
who runs content got very excited about
house of cards
and at that time it was a hundred
million dollars it was a fantastic
investment and it was in competition
with HBO and that was really the
breakthrough that he picked right up
front but I mean that was a significant
percentage of the revenue of the company
at that time but how could you get
confident that that was actually a worth
doing if you got that wrong it might
have been really devastating for the
company yeah we weren't confident I mean
that's the that's the whole tension of
it we're like holy I can't say that uh
the I was scary
and with that it wasn't just producing
new content you also pretty much with
that if I understand right introduce
this idea of binge viewing like you it
wasn't we're gonna do these episodes and
build excitement boom all at one time
and that consumer mode hadn't really
been tested why did you risk that well
you know we've grown up shipping DVDs
and then there was series box sets on
DVD and all of us had that experience
watching like some of the great HBO
content you know with the DVD next
episode next episode and so that was the
trigger to make us think wow you know
with episodic content especially
serialized it's so powerful to have all
the episodes at once and it's something
that linear TV can't do and so both of
those made it really positive and so did
it work out on on the math pretty much
straight away that an hour spent
watching house of cards say was more
profitable to you than an hour spent
watching someone else is licensed
content you know because we're
subscription we don't have to track it
at that level and so it's really about
making the brand stronger so that more
people want to join and house of cards
absolutely did that because then many
people would talk about it and associate
that brand with us whereas Mad Men we
carried great show with AMC show but
they didn't associate it with Netflix
even if they watched it on Netflix and
so you added all these other remarkable
series knockos Jessica Jones orange is
the new black the crown black mirror
that's my favorite stranger things and
so on and so and and I mean this coming
year the level of investment you're
planning to make in new content is not
100 million it's it's what it's about
eight billion dollars around the world
and and it's not enough there are so
many great shows on other networks and
so we have a long way to go but eight
billion that's pretty much higher than
any other content commissioner at this
point you're Disney's in that realm and
if they're able to acquire Fox they were
even bigger but
so and then really that's spread
globally and so it's not as much as it
sounds but clearly from the Barry
Diller's and others in the media
business it feels like from nowhere this
company has come and has really
revolutionized business and it's like is
this blockbuster one day said we're
going to make blockbuster videos and
then six years later was as big as
Disney I mean that that that story would
never have happened and yet it did
that's the about the Internet move
fast
everything around us moves really quick
I mean there must be something unusual
about Netflix is culture that allowed
you to take such bold I once a reckless
bold well thought through decisions yeah
absolutely I mean we did have one
advantage which is we were born on DVD
and we knew that that was going to be
temporary no one thought we'd be mailing
discs for a hundred years so then you
have a lot of paranoia about what's
coming next and that's part of the
founding ethos is really worrying about
what's coming next and so that's a
mangie
and then in terms of the culture it's
very big on freedom and responsibility I
pride myself on making as few decisions
as possible in a quarter and we're
getting better at better at that there
sometimes I can go a whole quarter
without making any decisions there are
some really surprising things about
about your people for example I I looked
at one survey it looks like Netflix
employees compared to peers are
basically the highest paid for
equivalent jobs and the least likely to
want to leave and if you google the
Netflix culture deck you see this list
of really quite surprising admonitions
to your employers talk about a few of
them well you know my first company we
were very process obsessed this was in
the 1990s and every time someone made a
mistake we tried to put a process in
place to make sure that mistake didn't
happen again so very semiconductor yield
orientation and the problem is we you
know we were trying to
we proved the system and then eventually
only dummies wanted to work there and so
then of course the market shifted in
that case it was C++ to Java but you
know there's always some shift and the
company was unable to adapt and it got
acquired by our largest competitor and
so with Netflix I was super focused on
how to run with no process but not have
chaos and so then we've developed all
these mechanisms super high talented
people alignment talking openly sharing
information and internally people are
stunned at how much information all the
court strategies etc we're like the anti
Apple you know how they can partner
analyze and we do the opposite which is
everybody gets all the information and
so what we're trying to do is build a
sense of responsibility and people and
the ability to do things and so I find
out about big decisions now that are
made all the time I've never even heard
about it which is great and mostly they
go well so you just wake up and read
them on the intranet that sometimes we
just tend to China yeah well that would
be a big one um but you allow employees
to set their own vacation time and like
that there's there's just that's a big
symbolic one vacation because if most
people in practice do that anyway but
yeah there's a whole lot of that freedom
and courage you ask for as a fundamental
value you know we want people to speak
the truth and we say you know to
disagree silently is disloyal it's not
okay to let some decision go through
without saying your piece and typically
writing it down and so we're very
focused on trying to get to good
decisions through and then you know the
debate that always happens and we try
not to make it intense like yelling at
each other or nothing like that
you know it's really curiosity drawing
people out you've got this other secret
weapon at Netflix it seems which is this
vast trove of data a word we've had a
certain amount about this week you've
often taken really surprising stances
towards building smart algorithms and
Netflix like back
the day you you opened up your algorithm
to the world and said hey can anyone do
better than this recommendation we've
got if so we'll pay you a million
dollars you paid someone a million
dollars yeah because it was like ten
percent better than yours that's right
was that was that a good decision in the
end would you do that again oh yeah
we're super exciting at the time this is
about 2007 but you know we haven't done
it again so clearly it's a very
specialized tool and so think of that is
that was a lucky break of good timing
rather than a general framework so what
we've done is invest a lot on the
algorithms and so that we feature the
right content to the right people and
try to make it fun and easy to explore
and you made this what seems like a
really interesting shift a few years ago
you used to ask people you know rate
you'll hear you know here are 10 movies
what do you think which ones of these
are your best movies and then try to
match those movies with recommendations
for what was coming and then you you
changed away from that talk about that
sure everyone would rate Schindler's
List 5 stars
and then they'd rate Adam Sandler you
know the do-over three stars okay but in
fact when you looked at what they
watched it was almost always Adam
Sandler okay and so what happens is when
we rate and we're metacognitive about
quality that's sort of our aspirational
self and it works out much better to
please people to look at the actual
choices that they make they're revealed
preferences by how much they enjoy
simple pleasures okay so this is I want
to talk for a couple minutes by this
because this strikes me as the huge deal
not just for Netflix for the internet as
a whole the difference between
aspirational values and revealed values
you brilliantly didn't pay too much
attention to what people said you watch
what they did and then found the stuff
that just oh my god I never knew I would
like a show about making horrible
recipes called nailed it Tom Miller
right it's hilarious but that I would
never even thought of that but aren't
there risks with this if this go only
with revealed values approaches is taken
too far well we get a lot of joy from
making people happy so
sometimes you just want to relax and
watch a show like nailed it and it's fun
and it's not stressful and other times
people want to watch a very intensive
film but bound was oscar-nominated it's
a great very intensive film and you know
we've had over 20 million hours of
viewing on mud bound which is
dramatically bigger than it would have
been in the theaters or any other
distribution and so you know yeah we
have some candy too but we have lots of
broccoli and you know if you have a good
mix you get to a healthy diet but yes
indeed but isn't it the case that our
algorithms tend to point you away from
the broccoli and towards the candy if
you're not careful we just had a talk
about how when on YouTube somehow
algorithms tend to but just by by
actually by being smart I tend to drive
people towards more radical or you know
specific content it'd be easy to imagine
that Netflix algorithms just going on
revealed values would gradually right
get to base and and we don't be watching
violent pornography or or something or
some people were and you know like how
me I'm the I'm the child of a missionary
I don't even think about these things
but but I mean it's possible right if in
practice you're right that you can't
just rely on algorithms you know it's a
mix of judgment and what we carry we're
a curated service versus a platform like
Facebook and YouTube so we we have an
easier set of issues which is what are
these great films and series that we
acquire but then within that the
algorithm is a tool but how since John
Doerr just talked about measuring what
matters I mean as a business what
matters I presume is is is fundamentally
disturbed in growing subscribers I mean
that's your that's your unique advantage
our subscribers grown only by more time
you know the more time they spend
watching Netflix that is what will make
them we subscribe or is it even more
about having shows that might not have
been so much time as watching the whole
season are nailed it
but but just get into them more they
just think that that was nourishing that
was extraordinary I'm so glad I watched
that with my family
isn't there a version of the business
model that would be less content but
more awesome content possibly even more
uplifting content and people choose that
uplifting content I think you're right
which is when people talk about Netflix
they talk about the shows that move them
13 reasons why or the crown or you know
and so that is way disproportionate and
positive impact even for the subscriber
growth that you talked about is those
couple big memorable shows but what we
want to do is offer a variety you know
you don't want to watch the same thing
every night as much as you like it you
want to try different things and what we
haven't seen is this a race to the
bottom of your violent pornography kind
of examples instead we've seen you know
great viewing across a whole range black
mirror you know we're filming season
five now and and that was a struggling
show when it was only in in the BBC and
and with the distribution of on-demand
you can make these much much bigger
shows you're telling me humans can get
addicted by their angels as well as
their demons yeah and again you know we
try not to think about an addiction
terms we think about it as you know what
are you gonna do with your you know your
time and when you want to relax and you
can watch linear TV you can do video
games you can do YouTube or you can
watch Netflix and if we're as great as
we can be and we have variety of moods
then more often people will choose us
but you have people in the organization
who are looking regularly at sort of the
the actual impacts of these brilliant
algorithms that you've created just for
reality check just are we sure that this
is the direction we want to go you know
well we I think we learn and you have to
be humble and sort of say look there's
no perfect tool how the algorithms one
part the way we Commission the content
our relationships with societies so
there's a lot of ways that we have to
look at it so if you get to Stockton
like let's just increase viewing or just
increase subscribers you're unlikely to
be able to grow and and be the great
company you want to be so think of it as
there's multiple measures
so speaking of algorithms that have
raised questions when you're on the
board of Facebook and I think Mark
Zuckerberg you've you've done some
mentoring for him what what should we
know about Mark Zuckerberg that people
don't know well many of you know amorous
'enum I mean is a fantastic human being
really first class and social whether
that's or these platforms that that's
YouTube or Facebook you know are clearly
trying to grow up quickly and we see
that with all new technologies I mean
yesterday we're talking about printed
DNA and it's like talk about you know
could be fantastic or could be horrific
and you know all new techno when
television was first popular in the
1960s in the u.s. it was called a vast
wasteland you know and the television
was gonna rot the minds of everybody and
it turns out everybody's minds were fine
and you know there were some adjustments
but so think of it I thought or I think
of it as all new technologies have pros
and cons and in social we're just
figuring that out how much of a priority
is it for the board of Facebook to
really address some of the issues or is
the belief that actually the company has
been completely unfairly criticized oh
it's not completely unfairly and marks
leading the charge on fixing Facebook
and he's you know very passionate about
that we don't want to look at another
passion of yours I mean you've done
incredibly well with Netflix you're a
billionaire and you spent a lot of time
and indeed money on on education yeah
why is this a passion and what are you
doing about it
sure right out of college I was a high
school math teacher and so when I later
went in a business and became a
philanthropist I think I gravitated
towards education and trying to make a
difference there and the main thing I
noticed is you know educators want to
work with other great educators and to
create many unique environments for kids
and we need a lot more variety in the
system than we have and a lot more
educator centric organizations and so
the tricky thing is right now in the
u.s. most schools
are run by a local school board and it
has to meet all needs in the community
and and in fact what we need is a lot
more variety so in the US there's a form
of school of public school called
charter public schools that are run by
nonprofits and that's the big emphasis
for me is if you can have schools run by
nonprofits they're more mission focused
they support the educator as well and
like I'm on the board of charter schools
which is one of the larger networks and
you know it's thirty thousand kids a
year are getting you know very
stimulating education I mean paint me a
picture of what a school should look
like what depends on the kid think about
it as you know with multiple kids
there's all different needs that need to
be met so there's not any one model and
you want to be able to choose depending
on your kid and what you think they need
but they should be very educator centric
and curious and stimulating and all of
those things in this whole idea of 30
kids in fifth grade all learning the
same thing at the same time you know
it's clearly a Industrial throwback but
changing that within the gift given the
current government structure is super
hard but what you know these innovative
nonprofit schools are doing is you know
pushing the bounds letting kids you know
try new things and so that's the think
of it as the governance reform that is a
nonprofit to allow the educational
changes and sometimes the criticism is
put that charter schools intentionally
unintentionally suck resources away from
the public school system should we be
concerned about that well they are
public schools so I mean there's these
multiple types of public schools and you
know if you look at charters as a whole
they serve low-income kids because if
high income kids get in trouble the
parents will send them to a private
school or they move neighborhoods and
low-income families generally don't have
those choices like Kipp you know it's
80% low-income kids free and reduced
lunch and the college admissions for
Kipp is fantastic read you signed the
giving pledge a few years ago you're
committed to giving away more than half
of your fortune during a lifetime can I
achieve a ask how how much you've
invested in education in the last few
years it's a couple hundred million I
don't know it
like how many hundreds but we're
continuing invest and thank you all and
you know it's honestly for a little
while I tried to do a politics full-time
and working for John doar and while I
loved working for John
I just didn't thrive on politics I love
business I love competing I love going
up against Disney and HBO and and you
know that's what gets me going and now I
do that to really you know increase
Netflix's value which allows me to write
more checks to schools and so it for now
it's the perfect life reach your
remarkable person you've changed all of
our lives and it collides with many kids
thank you so much for coming today
[Applause]